it's a calm ocean today but it wasn't
just a few hours ago welcome back to CBS
morning's crews are apparently working
Round the Clock trying to restore power
to the island of Puerto Rico after an
island-wide blackout due to Hurricane
Fiona but the Island's power grid if
we're being honest had problems even
before the hurricane five years after
Hurricane Maria many people there have
been dealing with constant outages which
in some cases can be life-threatening as
promised let's go back to our lead
National correspondent David begno who's
been talking to a lot of frustrated
people there on the island and David it
must be surreal for you exactly five
years after Maria came ashore killed 3
000 people and knocked out power to the
island again Puerto Rico is dealing with
power outages all across the island good
morning
good morning my friend yeah it's
disappointing we actually just got an
update we're now talking about 11
percent of customers who have power now
so it seems to be ticking up a whole lot
faster than it did after Maria so we're
going to see how does this private
Energy company perform this time and
that brings me to the story at hand we
came here nearly two weeks ago thinking
this was going to be the story today
never expecting another hurricane called
Fiona so here's the deal after Maria and
after Decades of mismanagement by the
power on the government-owned entity
they said you know what we're going to
hire a private company to handle
transmission and distribution on the
island they are going to fix everything
so 15 months ago this company Luma
energy came in so we called Lumen we
said what are the major upgrades that
you've done to the grid what are the big
ticket items that you want to show us
here's some of what we saw
Luma energy offered to show CBS News two
ways they're trying to fix the power
situation
starting with a tour of their training
facility in TOA Baja Puerto Rico they
introduced us to their latest class of
line workers 27 men and five women all
of whom are Puerto Rican and being
trained to be a part of the Island's
power solution second they took us to
see what they consider progress in
upgrading the transmission
infrastructure removing a wooden power
pole and replacing it with a hurricane
and earthquake resistant one we wanted
to speak with Loomis CEO Wayne stinsby
he said no problem until two days before
saying he couldn't due to personal
reasons so we took our questions to the
representatives offered up by the
company Don Cortez and noriette Figueroa
how much of the grid has been rebuilt we
are just basically starting to rebuild
the grid we have 209 active projects
that represent about 5.5 billion dollars
of federal federal dollars and the
reality is nothing has happened in terms
of rebuilding right how long do you
expect that to take Don we are
rebuilding the grid every day every day
we make improvements when we say we
haven't rebuilt we haven't started the
big projects right but we go out every
day and we rebuild segments of line we
rebuild poles we're rebuilding every day
what do you say to the people who are
experiencing basically light shows in
their own homes with the voltage going
in and out appliances that are being
ruined what's your message to them we
know exactly what the customer is saying
right and we know that they're speaking
pretty loud we all probably against most
of us we live here we do help outages in
our homes too does Luma energy have your
confidence
it's on on probation with me I am not
satisfied at the moment Puerto Rico's
Governor Pedro Pierre luisi was a
staunch advocate of luma when he took
office in 2021 when we spoke with him
nearly two weeks ago he told us the last
couple of power outages by their own
admission dealt with lack of maintenance
on critical transmission lines and that
that's not acceptable to me I know Luma
inherited a a very fragile grit and and
I know that the Reconstruction or the
rebuilding of this grid will take years
but that's what they were hired for
Endless outages have led people to
protest in the street and post their
frustrations on social media the lack of
accountability and professionalism by
the power companies according to the
Puerto Rico energy Bureau since Luma
energy took over 15 months ago pal GES
on the island last longer than they did
when the Island's bankrupt Power
Authority which managed the grid for
decades was in charge why is that so
when we came in last year was about
stabilizing the grid because it wasn't
really in a free fall without it just so
what we're doing is as we are improving
the service we are reducing the number
of outages now it's taking a little
longer because we're fixing the grid
we're not just going over there and
clipping one branch and that's it we're
making a more permanent fix on the on
the repairs we're doing how is Luma
doing in your opinion they're not doing
a good job they're failing on their job
for 17 years Jorge Bracero has worked
for Puerto Rico's Electric Power
Authority and now he's on the sidelines
watching his Luma energy responds to
outages it worries me because I lose
power every damn week
every week I got two small power plants
at home to small generators just to keep
my family
safe because now the outages are not one
hour
I can spend eight hours
that's not progress how you doing
welcome to my humble haul ew thank you
for having me it's nice to meet you nice
to meet you too we went to see 58 year
old Carol Ward she wrote to us saying
that she's a lung cancer patient on
oxygen around the clock and the power
instability on the island puts her life
at risk almost daily have you ever been
caught in a situation where the power
went out
and your battery backup died and you
didn't have oxygen yes really
yes there was three days almost four
days without power the power goes out
but the power bills don't stop coming
Ward lives on a fixed income of fifteen
hundred dollars a month and her power
bill is just as unpredictable as her
electricity it's uh frustrated and it
makes you feel hopeless
because you've been resilient since
Maria
uh here we were I have been gone
through many things
and now we are only surviving
because we don't have the money to pay
the light bill like here we used to pay
like uh
and 140 right now with 410 435.
and it's a lot so in April of this year
it was 140.
and it's jumped all the way up now to
400. correct has something changed about
your consumption no
we all have I want to remind you nearly
half the people living on the island
here U.S citizens in Puerto Rico live
below the poverty level about Carroll
some good news we posted on social media
when we interviewed her nearly two weeks
ago the mayor's office in biomone Puerto
Rico saw that post and they helped her
out they brought her a solar powered
generator so that's what she had to help
ride out this storm and she told us
she'd have all the oxygen she needs so
today it was the power tomorrow we've
got a report about the Health Care
System we've heard from doctors nurses
and patients who say David the Health
Care system is in collapse here you'll
hear from a researcher tomorrow who says
it's been in collapse for years but
since Maria it has accelerated that is
part two of our series of a series of
reports which airs here on CBS mornings
Tony
oh David well it's so glad to see you
back there on the island I know the
circumstances are not good but the
attention you bring to these issues uh
it helps speed people assistance where
they need it we just saw it in your
story there and we'll hear more about it
tomorrow so David thank you very much
more tremendous reporting from Puerto
Rico